Right now, you and I are watching a rotifer
just chill and do its rotifer thing.
The long thin strands of cilia that make up
its crown are whirling around to grab food,
while the organisms around it are caught up and diverted by the vortex the rotifer has created.
It’s a charming scene, as are so many of the other
scenes we’ve witnessed come out of the microcosmos.
Whether you’re watching this at home or
at work, we’re all sharing in these strange
and delightful moments courtesy of our strange
and delightful microscopic friends.
And we don’t mean to add a layer of existential
dread to the proceedings, but here’s something
to think about: by the time you watch these
scenes, the stars of the show that come in
and out of view are most likely long gone.
Perhaps they’ve been put back in the sample
jar, or maybe they’ve died on the slide.
They may even have entered a protective cyst
state.
Whatever path their lives have taken since
the moment they came into our view, we’ll
never be able to create these exact scenes
again.
So we’re lucky today to have a way to preserve
and share their lives in video.
And in the past, scientists turned to other
artistic means to document the microcosmos,
including illustration.
But sometimes, pictures and videos aren’t
enough.
Sometimes the best way to share what you’ve
seen under the microscope is, well, to share
the actual thing you’re looking at.
These slides that you’re looking at right
now were purchased from various auctions.
Inside them are diatoms collected from around
the world, some from Rio de Janeiro, others
from England, and some from the Mediterranean
Sea.
These are places we might not be able to visit
easily, and so who knows when we’ll be able
to collect some of their microscopic residents.
But thanks to the fellow lovers of microscopes
and microbes out there who collect and preserve
their samples, we can actually see a bit of
what they’ve seen with our own microscopes.
These prepared slides are meant to be permanent.
The goal is to be able to return to them at
a later date, perhaps with fresh eyes or under
a new microscope.
Maybe you’ve found a new species and want
to save it for later observation, or to convince
others that it’s truly real.
Or maybe you’ve just found something that’s
beautiful or cool, something that you think
others will want to see and learn from.
Whatever the motivation, the results—as
you can see here—are often stunning.
Now there are many ways to prepare samples
for microscopic study because there are many
different types of specimens to sample—from
microbes to pollen to organs.
When we study our own samples here, we’re
using what’s called a “wet mount”—our
little buddies are swimming around in a liquid,
in this case water.
We apply a bit of this watery sample to the
slide, enclose it with a coverslip, and then
we observe.
But to make these slides permanent, the microscopist
has to do things a little differently.
Again, these techniques can vary, but if we
were to follow one set of instructions we
found to prepare a permanent diatom sample,
we’d start by allowing our watery microbe
mix to settle on a coverslip until the thin
layer of water has evaporated away.
Then we would add a mounting medium to the
slide and turn the dry, diatom-coated coverslip
onto it, allowing the medium to seep in and
preserve the organisms left behind.
We are definitely simplifying this process
for narrative effect.
But we want to note that because of the volatile
compounds in the mounting process, the instructions
also contain a specific note to perform this procedure in a fume hood (among other safety precautions).
So we recommend that anyone seeking to make
these prepared slides do a bit more research
on the best and safest methods for their needs.
You may have noticed already that the diatoms
we are watching in these prepared slides bear
a strong resemblance to the living diatoms we’ve watched countless times on this channel before.
But they’re also a bit different, with the
colors and shapes shifted just slightly, as
if we’re watching them through a filter.
This is likely due to the use of acid to remove
their organic parts, erasing much of their
biological contents from our view, but leaving
behind the stunning silicon frustules that
diatoms encase themselves in.
The result feels a bit like roaming through
the dioramas in a natural history museum,
with scenes from nature rendered on the other
side of the glass to suggest a living world
that does not actually live.Those dioramas
have the stillness and sense of distance that
a photograph does, but they are also their
own direct experience that is shaped by the
setting you observe them in.
In that same way, these permanent slides are
their own unique perspective of a static microcosmos,
informed as much by the people who made them
as they are by their later observers.
And these slides have been letting microscopists
preserve and share the objects of their fascination
for centuries.
Around the mid-1800s, microscopy became kind
of a thing—particularly in Britain.
Manufacturers were producing more affordable
microscopes, and users were publishing guides
to help others use this tool to navigate the
unseen world.
Amateur and professional microscopists began
to form groups like the Quekett Microscopical
Club, united by the curiosities on the other
side of the lens.
The slides they prepared carried everything
from beard hairs to insect exoskeletons to diatoms.
And more than a century later, people still
collect these slides, studying their contents
not just to observe the worlds mounted within them, but also to understand the people who made them.
And just as art museums have to verify and
conserve the works produced by old masters,
museums and collectors have to handle these
microscope slides with care.
As one collector noted, these slides can sometimes
sell for thousands of dollars, attracting
forgers whose false work becomes apparent
in fonts that are too modern and cuts that
are too uneven.
And the authentic slides require maintenance
as well, whether their surfaces need to be
cleaned of grime or their contents re-preserved.
The fascination and attention these centuries-old
slides inspire feels like a natural extension
of microscopy both as a hobby and a scientific
pursuit.
We’ve heard from many of you that the footage
we share on this show has made you want to
buy a microscope, to sample the world around
you to see what it contains.
And what are these slides except just another
way microscopists have been sharing the natural
world with each other?
These slides don’t show us the microcosmos
as it once existed as much as they reflect
the journey the microcosmos itself has taken, through solvents and hands and elements.
Through microscopists and collectors.
And then, of course, to you.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you especially to all of the people
here on the screen right now who are some
of our supporters on Patreon, where we now
have a $2 tier that includes access to a Journey
to the Microcosmos Discord.
And if you want to learn more about that you
can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, james weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, There’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.